I know you hosted Saturday Night Live
and you say you don't really get nervous
you say you don't get anxiety I don't
know how one wouldn't get a little
anxiety when they're going on National
Television to do Saturday Night Live you
had to be nervous yes I was nervous for
style life but in the good way like
I remember this the exhilar it was
exhilarating which to me what felt like
a mix of like
you're nervous but it was just I felt
like I was in good hands they were all
so prepared and so like this is what's
gonna happen this is what's gonna happen
and it was it was a weird ride I'm
telling you like if it was now I would
be more
feel like it would be more nervous but
I'd be more professional so maybe I
wouldn't be as nervous there I was just
kind of riding the coast I was always
professional like but I would probably
you know input more jokes and put more
writing but come up with more you let
them do their thing yeah it was just
like hey I'm kind of here along for the
red I don't know what I'm doing and uh
but I'll do my best but I was so young
and still green and I just I mean
creatively I still had a lot to you know
really
kind of you know Blossom I suppose so
um so it was a great experience but I
was definitely like
I was nervous leading into it but also
like using those nerves and just like
let's ride this wave baby and uh and
have fun and it was it was a blast I
mean I was like I'd easily do this again
wow did you hear that Lord I'd easily do
this again
uh that's amazing it just seems like
gosh there's so much going on Lauren's
like yeah okay do another hip moving and
maybe I'll let you in yeah getting
another hit movie